[Applause]
MLB the show has always been interested
in creating a hard-hitting realistic and
most of all an immersive baseball game
the PlayStation exclusive comes in hot
next month with its latest entry in the
series MLB the show 19 and there are a
lot of improvements you can look forward
to one of the biggest changes has to be
the overhauled system that the show 19
uses for its defensive players
everyone loves seamed studs out there in
the outfield flashing the leather and
making spectacular catches replicating
these moments in game feels great but
you can't have every player have the
same skill tier as say a Matt Chapman
that's why the devs behind the show make
sure that skill differences on defense
and your ability matters so much more
all the attributes that contribute to
your defensive player success are closer
to their real-life counterparts so if
you have your stud left fielder suddenly
playing on the opposite side of the
field odds are you may be prone to
mistakes players with lower skill
attributes may even get a bad jump
towards the ball and with over 1300 new
animations your fielders can put in some
serious work to help you make a double
play that'll get your blood pumping with
all the defensive improvements in play
let's talk about something else in
baseball that everyone loves contact
that bat the show 19 is introduced the
method that rewards your skill at
batting and lets you improve by judging
how you swing and even how well you can
take your pitches after all even the
pros are making only about 30% of their
hits so how do you balance this in a way
to where you can feel empowered and can
start making meaningful hits well you
make contact hitters matter baseball
players who are known to spread the ball
out with SiC line drives are on
different pockmarks of the field are now
more relevant than ever before by adding
a level of depth to your lineup this
encourages you to play to your bat or
strengths rather than just constantly
mashing or flicking your stick for the
standard swing there's a lot more coming
up with MLB the show 19 the fans of the
series will love to see and we'll have a
lot more to share with you in the near
future stay tuned to games.com for all
the reviews videos and features you love
see you on the Mount
[Applause]
[Music]